you
[Music]
so I will talk today about something
different not related to search is
explain every eye that was Peters choice
so it's his fault and my main work is an
intent intent if a company based in
California lived in Green Team where we
are doing semantic search and also
conversational search like conversation
III so if you need any white technology
to do semantic search or conversational
AI we can provide search as a service
there so this is the agenda so first I
will explain what is attainable AI for
people that hasn't seen that then
explain why we need that then how we
solve it I will give you some examples
and then I will discuss responsibly I
and that means transparency
accountability furnace you can find a
whole different talk I have in the web
about bias which is one of the main
problems today especially data bias so I
think you don't need to know this but I
have this for all the people that say
that says AI amateur learning and then
don't they don't know the mature
learning is part we are and then I get
like please if you say that don't don't
say it because it's like saying the egg
and the York one is inside the other
okay so I will have keep this because
I'm sure you know all of this but it is
for people that usually don't know that
we have more data and more power today
and and that's the reason why we can use
neural networks with many many layers
than before and then you get deep
learning and this is a list of things
that we can do with that but and then we
want to learn we want to predict we want
to prescribe these are the three goals
however now we will need to explain to
to explain to other people why we are
doing things so before starting let's
talk about complexity so let's say you
have
complexity in the y-axis and data in the
x-axis so without too much problem you
can take pictures of anyone here and do
a classifier that basically will
distinguish me from anywhere anyone else
that's not too difficult you don't need
big data you can do it with small data
if you get something like instance
famous formula for mass and energy of
course that formulas trivial after a
stand founded
but that's the data why is big data
because it applies to any object in the
universe
so basically generalize to every object
now we can try to predict the stock
market let's say Wall Street that's a
very complex problem doesn't matter use
a big data small data it's not possible
to predict because there are people
behind people are not rational the best
proof that you cannot predict it will be
that you will be here trying to predict
it but if you do that then there is no
stock market right doesn't make sense to
have a stock market that can be
predicted and then we can go to
something much more complicated I told
you right the classifier to distinguish
any animal in this picture I hope you
know the garden of delights of Bosch so
that's very hard because the animals are
not standard animals and if you have
chained your relevant with image net of
course will fail so that's something you
can solve but you need big date so who
is trainable er so this started mainly
like three years ago with a problem in
DARPA they call it shy and if you know a
bit of Catalan try could be confused
here by lamb but it's not that and the
question is how explain a person why the
model took certain decision is the the
key the key question so we need to put
explanation and we to replace the usual
normal model here
by explanation of why this happened
let's say I didn't get the mortgage why
it happened the car did something stupid
why it happened and so on so why we need
it these are some reasons that's why we
need it first we need to verify the
system so this is transparency we need
to be able to know what is happening the
second reason is for us is to explain
but to ourselves for example how we can
improve the system are fulfilling the
goals of the system you may have
different goals and different trade-offs
are in the right place it's where we
want to be for example we are predicting
an illness sometimes it's better to over
predict the illness because you don't
want the person to die and you don't
mind sending people that is not ill to
the doctor because they will be happy
after seeing the doctor so that
sometimes you need to play with the
false negatives and the false positives
the third reason is to learn from the
system and that would be called fallacy
can we learn why something happened it's
not only about correlations is about
cause an action and you can read the
book of why anyone here read the book of
Y okay a few person if you like if you
have to think of solitude you can read
that book nutrition because we are
forced to do it legal reasons ethical
reasons so 50g DPR and I will get back
to the deeper and then furnace and
that's the topic that is also very
important I will not cover today but
furnace with gender furnace with race
furnace with religions furnace with
geography furnace with language so for
example today anything you do with text
is biased to gender most texts are
written by men so there's no such thing
as unbiased text I haven't seen that and
even if you take women texts sometimes
you have the opposite
my F for obvious reasons because they
can write in the sense that they cannot
write as much as men because can that
can be misinterpreted I don't know if
you know this example is a very it is
examples appear last year so this is a
paper that was able to change just one
pixel in an image using three standard
techniques for image recognition that
come from deep learning and then with
one pixels that were able to change the
prediction of that system so for example
here this deer became an airplane or
this ship became a car just by changing
this pixel one single pixel so what
these models are doing with one single
pixel they change aren't really the
learning quota Sudhir or are just
learning patterns by conscience and I
think is closer to a second than to the
first it's not real intelligence let me
give you three examples of bias I think
I have three examples here so these are
data from the UK you can find similar
data from the US so if you are a black
person well your probability is going to
prison if you go to court goes at least
four times larger than if you're white
in fact your white your poverty
decreases so you would do any system
that even don't take the demographics in
account and there's a very interesting
paper by train well at all using a New
York justice system the Alvin will learn
to be write racist even if you use just
the age of the person however even that
is racist will be better than judges why
because they do the say always the same
judges are very bearable depends on if
they sleep well if they had lunch or not
and so on so this is much more fair in
the sense that for the same kind of
crime do you get the same kind of
penalty today justice is really prefer
not to talk about that really bad in
many countries so if you are interested
in this you can read this paper and also
there's a talk available in several
versions in the web so these are the
vicious cycle of bias in the web which
is one main case of public data but if
something that is not only in the
daytime are also in the algorithms very
important in the interfaces for example
self feedback loops and so on so if you
are working in personalization be very
careful you can write your own destiny
okay so last year there was a very
interesting interview done in wire - -
Hinton Hinton is one of the fathers of
the learning and they want the Turing
award this year with laocoön and thank
you and he basically is against
explaining AI and you can read the
interview only have one question here so
one of the kids he said that basically
if you ask a person to explain something
the person will make up the story and
guess that's true but I'm sure you will
make up a story that is true it's not
like an invention and here is one with
one answer from a person Australia he
says maybe he's making up a story about
these two so basically a lot of experts
and informers answer this interview
saying is nonsense
we need to explain even if it's
difficult well for many reasons you can
read the joke this another reason
sometimes so remember in the US the
police all we will ask you do you know
why I stopped you because of you say why
then you're guilty but now you can ask
the car in the future cars will be able
to speak maybe the car would say don't
stop me I get the fine sign i I know I
did something wrong and then that goes
to round ability a very important
problem that is not solved today
for example can behold an AI system
accountable like a robot should and a
system have rights you know there's some
people talking about rights for robots
and we still don't have them so they
imagine some science-fiction movie in
the future but if you talk to a lawyer a
lawyer will say that there are three
kinds of any legal entities people
corporations and in some cases their
idols idols like a physical God in one
country there is one river that is an
idol but it's a very specific reason to
protect the river even that the river
can speak for itself
so the real thing is that there was
another case in the US that too pathetic
a chimpanzee they tried to make the
chimpanzee a legal entity at the end the
Supreme Court said no the chimpanzee is
not a legal entity so no animal other
than us are legal entities so robots
will be even less they are not conscious
so I think talking about mentality is
very hard so then we have the question
who will should be accountable the
people that prepare the training data
the people that label the training data
the people that train the model the
people that implement the day and user
interface the owner of that software
very hard different different percentage
if they were different companies that's
an assault problem and we need to solve
it in the future but of course the
answer is no we cannot make systems
accountable that will break down all our
society we will need to build a
different society where things are very
different for example if you read
johanna Bryson's blog
she says that robots should be slaves in
the good sense of the world we created
them they should work for us they should
work to make our life better they are
not really living beings so these are
all the possible places where you can
have some someone accountable
and will be very happy in the future if
the function what happens to the site
who is accountable and to androids will
provide with a special contracts where
accountability will give will be really
forwarded to other parties so if you buy
if you buy data now the data will say we
are not accountable for the usage of
this data this is the future suddenly so
Jornal also has some different levels of
explanations so the first one is will be
the Hinton's choice no explanation it's
too hard too difficult people will make
up story the second possibility is
explain the human actions that led to
the fifth M do something and this is
important for accountability for
understanding or for example explaining
put inputs resulted in hot outputs and
here we have two different cases one I
want to do experiment experiments with
the black box I will get back to that
when I show one way to do it when
ability and then the other possibility
is to have a record for later analysis
like black boxes in an airplane so you
can inspect them and understand why that
wrapper all for example could be seen
exactly how the system works this is the
most difficult so you see there in level
of difficulty and for example could be
good documentation something that
usually we don't do well we don't like
to write documentation we'd like to
write code right or for example gas
making the model more transparent
explain more about the model for example
which are the main features which
changes will make which other change and
so on so of course one is not an option
we need to explain for legal and ethical
reasons and then to I will say is
compulsory you need to do two and then
maybe you need to do three when there's
people involved if you may harm people
you need to do three this will be at
least the minimum for externality
so the other question is do we always
need shy well no of course not
now in in the European Union we use a DM
automatic decision-making doesn't matter
if the program is with machine learning
or not if any any program could be a
switch for example a switch in customs
that you get a random green light or red
light this could be automatic
decision-making so when do I need to do
it well many systems don't have any
consequence
like for example web advertising or a
mistake on sending a letter like postal
code salting that's okay all the other
cases the problem is so difficult and in
real time that is much better than
people that we need to have the system
otherwise will be much worse and the
best example today is basically our
controllers traffic control the system
doesn't get tired then work 24 hours
without stop and may react faster than
people people maybe they're just for
special cases so this is the question
which system should have a I explained
over I which ones do not so this is the
explanation framework this is a zoom of
something I had before so you have an
extra explainable model you have
exponential interface this is the person
that wants to know what happened and in
some cases the problem that this person
is not there this will be automatic
decision-making and there we need to
remember these are predictions have you
seen a classifier that says I don't know
I don't know why we're afraid to say I
don't know point what is it or not like
the special is too low we shouldn't say
say cut because we don't have an idea
that's exact
so these are predictions a minute and
the predictions are wrong because
programmers force to have a result when
the result should be I don't know
and in that case would eat
contestability would eat one process to
be able to say tell me why this happened
and I hear a have a disagreement and we
need to revise this decision and there
have been cases in the u.s. that that
happened and then there are many
challenges like linear model explained
efficient used explanation and depending
on the type of application like data
analytics or autonomous systems this
will be different and I will go a bit
fast here because I don't think I have
much time so let me give you an example
this could be a one neural network you
have a cut this the current output
difficult this could be a small
explanation it has four wishes and close
as this feature does I don't know how it
calls that these kind of ears are a
special this could be an explanation
well there are different ways to
approach the problem so could be
comprehensible could be interpreted or
could be completely apart this will be
the current case and here we go here and
one possible solution is to use
reasoning for example the reasoning will
be typically factories have lights have
concrete have boxes and so on and then
you can explain why it's more a
description but sometimes in the
scripture is a good explanation
but the explanation may be difficult so
anyone knows which animal is this one
which animal a cat for us is very simple
give this image to a mod a machine
learning model from that was training
for with image net or something signal
will not get with the difficulty will
get this an animal because has
considered it's their sphere but will be
very difficult so if you like science
fiction with the last question from
team up one of the best stories ever
written and this is point v fa i don't
know I don't know I don't have anything
on the training data for this okay so
how we solve the problem where they are
two basically approaches to solve this
problem some others are easy to explain
like for example if you have a deficient
tree the Ephesian tree itself is kind of
explanation now if you have a random
forest 200 trees are not so easy to
explain and neural networks of the
hardest to explain because we're ready a
black box system so the question is how
we solve this so here I have some
reference I will not go into detail but
there have been some work in the last
four years about explaining deep
learning here there are two different
techniques one is called letter wise
relevant data is called sensitivity
analysis and the problem that depend on
the machine learning technique gives so
you will need one technique method and
this a bit too much but we can do
something that is completely agnostic
and this is one of the basic samples
three years old is called lime lime
comes from local interpretable model
explanation and basically it's like
doing an experiment so taking the black
box and doing experiments and here what
I have in blue and this more like white
is the regional model of course we don't
know the model and then the model is
doing experiment and is discovering that
this kind of a line here so basically
discovering the disable frontier using
examples so this an example applied for
this very hard thing this a dog with a
shirt with a person behind so if we have
to know if with a dog or a person but
for example here is the explanation of a
dog this is basically only the head and
one of their paws here but you can get
problems and this is a classical problem
for example this explanation of a husky
and mainly the explanation is that there
is a snow
behind and it's a famous paper where
everything that had a snow behind was a
wolf
and everything else was a dog so the
system learned that behind wolves
usually there is no but sometimes there
Huskies and then it's wrong so this is
the problem we don't know put the 15 is
running and it's not learning what you
think it's running even when the system
this is a cat and it's right doesn't
really know for this a couple we know
what is a cat then the cat notes go to
second but not the system I think I will
skip this so so for example
interpretability you needed for gdpr
and completeness you needed for for
example explaining some mistake or
making decisions for wrong reasons and
if you read this paper that appear last
year you have a taxonomy and best
practices about this and I don't have
time to fold this so I will skip it
disappear anyone has read articles Tony
took here how many people have read
articles in it'll only two three okay
but you don't need to read it after this
is this the whole article okay clearly
is written by lawyers but the most
important key thing here is at the end
it says to express his or her point of
view and to contest the decision oh this
is that fundamental you need to have
contest abilities by law at least in the
European region the problem with it is
easier that this is been enforced for
everyone I think as a mistake to enforce
it for the bakery or the newspaper stand
it's okay to forces in a large
corporation but they enforce to
everybody and now there are lawyers
making other money with small small
shops so what it means so this is a
translation to to our times so we need
to give people information about the
processing so if you are using M L that
means you need interpretability or for
example simple ways for a request human
intervention or challenge the decision
they want have stability and
case you may need to explain this is the
hardest case and for example this is not
something you do once if something you
need to keep doing and if the model
changes this will change too so you need
to maintain legal and ethical issues or
they talk about accountability today
there's a lot of gray areas for legal
accountability and of course the law
will be different every country so can
we have an international consensus on
this can we agree for example when to
use face recognition for example now you
might have seen at San Francisco City
already banned any kind of face
recognition while if you go to Singapore
it's normal so that's not easy to decide
so two years ago the ACM US policy team
and part of one of these committees
publish a statement of the seven
properties that Algrim should fulfill I
will not read the properties but these
are the properties so how many albums do
you know that fulfill these seven
properties one property this is the
problem even one property might be hard
and if we don't do it right and lawyers
will do it right and this will be much
worse because they will not do it right
but will be a problem there will be a
business software will be very expensive
so DDP are the new copyright directive
false here too and very important all
rules don't have to be perfect they just
need to be better than us but some
people forget that many algorithms will
be much better than us like judges for
sure others will be better cars our
goals will be better but we need to
decide what that means to be better so
some bad human practices I will not read
all of them but I want to point some of
them which are important so things like
reusing code in a different context I
can like UNIX is a case you know the
original purpose of UNIX was not to be
an operating system dynamic of
fifteen five fifteen a problem from the
design initially and so on failing to
mention impact of the port system after
our disability and so on or for example
in acrid data or just data
I'm sure do some of some of you played
with the image net roulette so how many
people did play with image net wallet
okay how many years it took to say yeah
the collection the change collation is
not good so until someone contest
something people keep using something
that even when is wrong but if we do
wrong things sometimes not that bad so
you can read the job so if we keep
having people not to connect check in a
day later we may survive when the robots
prevail because they use the wrong data
so there are some hard learning problems
I want to two of them anyone has read
this short story so this was a person
that couldn't forget so we had the bad
idea of asking him how was your morning
he would take three hours to tell you
how was his money so he had no friends
so the brain is very good at filtering
our brain abstract many things a kid can
see three cards and they can recognize
the picture of the cut that I'll show
you from below we are very good at that
at having a knowledge representation
that abstracts a lot of things and the
federal one is that the current levels
not in the data and sometimes people
forget that training data has to be a
good sample of the whole problem space
for example if you have people half
women half men if you have different
colors the same shares
everything should be fair and this is
not true today so this is hard to learn
because then you need to have also
pictures from all anama from below a gas
a glass table which is very hard for
some animals so yet get below a lion to
get a picture of a lion
okay so firm recommendations based on
the on the bots packages so the Sun for
people first understand the limitations
of our systems I think that this type of
I love deep learning but it's a hype it
is not intelligence at least let's
differentiate intelligence from deep
learning learning from the past doesn't
mean to reproduce it problem using text
and you reproduce and amplify gender
bias code of ethics explain ability more
cross discipline evaluation very
important don't use human in the loop if
we're in the loop we are not the Masters
the system is the master we are in
control machines and in the loop we are
the Masters we define the system so we
need to remember that okay so the future
this is what I'm really worried about I
see it in every election the last one
sub Z was in Brazil I've done also
Brazilians here and they disagree with
me but I've seen this in many countries
yes
so why I'm worried I would like to quote
Haredi anyone read Travis last book 21
lessons for the delaford century ok you
have read everything so I will recommend
it I don't agree with karate all
completely I'm an optimist he is a
pessimist and I had the I talked to him
once but he's right and so many things
is right because otherwise this will
happen prove the era of the human there
are no more humans correct
hahahaha and this will happen not
because the robots kills the human this
happens because the humans kills
themselves right and we need to avoid
that so without future this is what
karate believes the humans can be Hacket
that free will is an illusion if you
talk if you talk to neuroscientist he
will also say yes free will is an
illusion but we need the delusion to
live otherwise will not be able to live
will get depressed maybe loss of jobs
for some reason something is not a pill
on the right in the right time so I
think the the animation is I will have
to go all the way because I want to okay
so you must can be hacked I would like
to say maybe just the easy parts so how
many people here can believe that that
can be hockey in the soccer team that
you like that's harder odd or hacked or
laugh for your significant other I hope
the scholar but seen the politic is very
easy there's a very interesting world by
by a neuroscientific north system
Lisa Feldman Barrett she says that
emotions is like mature learning it's
something that you learn to predict when
you're a kid but the most important
thing of that is that you can change
your prediction consciously and I have
applied that and you can do it so next
time that you do something else undo
practice just don't do it and you will
surprise the other the other side
because he was that person is predicting
that that reaction and you react
differently lots of jobs well we can
leverage AI we can have more leisure
later on art if someone is willing to
pay me some basic salary I will do other
things I will be talking all the time
and when they're better than humans how
many people here cannot get to a place
without the GPS this is volume we are
losing something very basic that we
learn 100 thousand years ago we're very
good at finding locations about hunting
and all that but now people cannot do it
the rest is very hard to argue because
if that's true
a network is more complex and
individuals so which would be like bees
and ants to be able to be like a network
and this may be true so I hope he's
wrong so what we can do and I will I
will paraphrase Hari because I think he
had a very good answer for this this was
an interview he gave in a Stanford that
I will attend it and have some of my own
too but he said there are three things
we can do first one learn yourself
better I hope already did that most
other people do that very early some
people never do it
that's a null problem and for example he
said I should assert myself earlier he a
sceptic himself much later because of
others reasons if you know about Holly
the second is also very interesting work
more in decentralized systems and this
is mine please go beyond blockchain we
can do much better blockchain is
technologically awful so it's not
efficient there are many problems but I
guess there is only way that people have
found to do this order in many cases
there are other cryptographic techniques
that you can use and they sell what is
the most interesting one and this may be
a future business we need AI armors so
basically a system that will tell us
when someone is trying to manipulate us
okay I want that and of course the
question will be well but the big combat
will have better AI well but we will
have better data and something very
important for me the Ferrari didn't say
that
we'll also teach about our biases for
example we'll love to to someone the
system that after my talk said you said
all these things are buyers next time
don't say that right I would like that
or you wrote this why you don't use this
word instead of this work and we we
don't see it because it's inside biases
completely part of us okay so to end no
privacy if you want health maybe we will
not have any privacy this is my
nightmare if we don't do it well
software assurance will appear because
we were not able to decide who's
accountable
do we have open to humanity people with
more money will be superhumans more
inequality that will be enough for world
to live but something a little challenge
is still I think it's good and someone
said if you are is the Silicon Valley
you have to be optimist but also Silicon
Valley is like a black hole you cannot
get out of it and I'm feeling that now
so anyone read this book the naked Sun
ok yeah you have one book didn't read
good so this is a world where everything
was done by robots and then humans
didn't see need to see each other so
every human had like thousand square
kilometers and live apart from each
other and the novel is basically about
one crime that would never happen at
that time and then people have to see
each other because of the detective
looking at this problem but here I'm
looking more like this world not that
not the whole book so the world is
basically we're only talking through
internet also even today some people
talk only through the phone even they
are together so this is the future all
the people like this even that we're
together I don't know but if there are
nice aliens out there please
come soon so arrival will be my favorite
movie someone that forced us to live
together better and I will finish with
this quote from Hardy this is the
pessimistic part I hope this is not true
thank you hey and I was wondering what
you see as the biggest blocker towards
widespread adoption of AI armors so like
corporations or governments regulation
like a change in zeitgeist what do you
see is the single biggest thing that
should happen to have this happen to
have it so I don't think is I don't
think is regulation because it's already
regulated gdpr is very clear about this
so GDP is forcing to do this so I will
say right now if that we don't know
exactly how to do it so I will say if
science is to computer scientists
working more a lot of people is working
with there are no standards on that for
example we need to I guess it's more
like the industry need to reach
consensus there's some AI consortiums
today and they're working on that but if
someone doesn't say ok line will be the
standard you need to do line this could
be a possibility it's not the best way
but that this is agnostic to the
technique and you could do it very fast
ok you are forced to do let's say 1
million tests with lime and and test the
system to for general bias for race bias
for forever we need to test legally for
example if that affects people so I will
say the standards is the main problem
today so we don't know what to do I hope
is not resistant from the programmers
that will be another problem yeah yeah
you said mentioned that when AI causes
some horrible catastrophe or causes some
dev sources some other consequences
there will come some regulation
accordant basically to limit how the
software or a I should be used so how do
you have any idea
how we should we should it be regulated
or will it be how should it will be
regulated basically so so that's a good
question I think GDP art is one extreme
maybe I'm not in that part but I will
say the ones I put in green should be
regulated but the last one should left
to the industry so for example how much
we explain to the industry but for
example when I sell farm
I didn't mean physical crime like
killing somewhere I mean any kind of
crime because for example not giving a
mortgage to someone that really needed
will hunt that person too so I'm saying
harm in any social sense so for any
system that affects the life of people
which would have it so I think that
should be regulated today if there's
some regulation for example regarding
financial institutions that you have to
explain to the people the main reasons
why a decision was taken but not exactly
say they details for example the problem
while you are sorry but they don't know
is how little is to the forefront or the
threshold to to get the mortgage but
these things are already regulated
partially in some countries but we need
the regulation because otherwise these
more work for people will not do it like
any regulation like accessibility you
know have to be regulated so people do
it hi you mentioned about bringing human
in the loop in order to bring the
transparency but if you look you also
shown some of the stats about how a
biased human decision impacting that
crime activity in all those things and
humans are inherently biased do you
think like what do you think bringing
human in the loop brings more
transparency to the a or do you think
like the problem is not an AI but a a
sin a reflection of whatever whatever
the bias already has in the society
clearly and all these models amplified
at this keep and sometimes amplify the
bias so
the first thing which would be that the
15 should be aware of their benefit and
this is not difficult to do because we
are defined in systems but the second
thing I would like to see is that the
system if we even have a person that is
basically having this explanation
conversation with the system the system
also should make aware of our biases so
if the human says I will do this the
system should do but this is bias
because of these these are these reasons
we have sometimes we are not aware so
you say it's a double game where the
system should be aware of itself and
also it should make us aware of our our
biases and this is something that is
also seeing a pending pending issue
because no one is talking about that I
think even if we have system that only
makes a world of our bias we will be
better and then we can take the
officials better as this more fair even
that if initially we didn't think those
were fair so people can change
[Music]